okay guys red pill Coffee Talk part two
I was thinking yesterday
how we are literally Outsourcing
families
and our whole society is built for
individuals it's not built for families
now
guys if you like these type of talks you
want more updates on what I'm doing all
that stuff sign up for my email list
it's in the description
um
we're trying to throw events sorry I
have to plug this in we're trying to
throw events we're trying to
get
like we're trying to do red pill boxing
masks and sometimes I just want to
update you guys on my thoughts like this
but okay sign up in the description okay
back to Outsourcing families so I was
thinking about I was at the gym okay and
I was thinking about how everyone in the
gym was single and they're by themselves
and I was thinking about how a lot of
them had like could have had a family
right
but I was just thinking about how
everything in society is built
four individuals now and it's not built
for families so before how would you get
in shape
now
I'm thinking I mean more than a hundred
years ago
where people really lifting weights like
that I could be wrong historians
Pearl's just given her thoughts about
Society but housework and farm work like
when I was doing the kneading the bread
by hand and the stirring by hand I was
thinking like wow I could see why the
women were in such great shape because
you stir for like 30 minutes your arm
gets tired and I bench a plate I can
bench a lot
and I was just thinking how even though
I'm in shape like those women were in
better shape in a different way because
I'm stirring and while I can you know
pick up a lot of weight for 30 seconds
like Stern for an hour would Tire me out
and how many calories are you burning
doing that stuff you're probably
naturally in just great shape and so how
are you getting in shape you're
literally getting in shape by spending
time with your kids
because you're in the house your kids
are there
and you're doing it together and it was
the same thing with housework right
I was thinking about how
you might
you might have someone
that does housework for you well who did
you do the housework with before as a
family right you you and your kids or
whatever would do the work together and
right okay so then then
let's go to family advice okay you used
to if you were having marriage troubles
if you were having
issues with a a sister or brother who
would go you would go to your family
mediator and
who was the family mediator okay usually
a sibling maybe your mother maybe your
father and those people involved have a
vested interest in having you not turn
out crazy because and they can see the
results so they can see what happens to
you after you get this advice and after
you get the advice I'll give you an
example okay
I have one sister I have five sisters
one of my sisters is a bit of a hothead
so if she tells me a story okay I'm
gonna interpret it a completely
different way than if another sister
tells me a story so
if Sister B who's not a hot head
tells me a story and that someone's
being rude to her I'm gonna think that
that person was a dick if Sister a tells
me a story about someone being rude to
her
well I'm gonna think maybe she did
something first because she's a bit of a
hothead I have that information a random
therapist not gonna have that
information now why
why
do we go to therapists now it's because
it's because
people don't have big families now I was
looking up the average kid's like family
size 100 years ago it was five kids
so five kids was the average size so if
you have four siblings okay and two
parents
one of them's bound to give good advice
one of them's bound to be The Peacemaker
of the family and you know now we're
going to strangers where they're going
to the internet to get advice
and it's not necessarily the kid's fault
like I mean I'd say we I don't know
therapists I go to I try I did try
therapy for a very short period of time
I was like this [__] I'm getting out
of here I used something to talk about
my problems how is that going to improve
them
so okay back to the back to the
therapist so
back to the therapist so so
one of your siblings is bound to be good
at advice and if let's say you don't
like the advice from one you could go to
another and all of the problems stay in
the family
that's because you've a vested interest
in not wanting dirt to get out about
your family now you know you might if
you have a problem with your sister you
might go tell a close family friend but
it doesn't help you to get around the
town knowing that your family's fighting
so you have a vested interest in keeping
secrets you have a vested interest in
having a good family name now the
problem is I don't really blame Our
Generation for it because if you're born
to a single mother home or a single
father home but like let's be honest
single mother home I think I saw a stat
that 80 percent
of kids nowadays are born into single
parent households
eighty percent so
if you're one of the 80 of people that
was born into a single parent home
and you have no siblings who else are
you gonna go to for a dice advice you
you have your mother and if your mother
is crazy then you have no options you
have to go to strangers so that's
internet therapists coaches
um teachers so now you're getting
strangers involved in a family affair
and it's the same thing we Outsource we
even Outsource the sex talk okay because
before
your parents would sit you down and have
a conversation about the birds and the
bees and a parent is gonna know more
about each kid okay I'll give you an
example
two sisters right one sister you know
some of these Brothers Two Brothers
right I'm not gonna you know one brother
one brother
he
was a crazy kid he needed the sex talk a
lot earlier than the other brother the
other brother was a bit of a nerd not
really dealing with girls not really you
know kind of like Nick Fuentes like how
soon did his parents really have to have
the sex talk my other brother needed
that immediately now the parents know
more information than again the school a
stranger so now we're Outsourcing having
a conversation with your children
to a school
so now it's like again it's like the
breakdown of the family it's like all of
this stuff is contributing to things
that should be in the family versus
outside of the family
same thing with friends right you're
supposed to have one two three close
family friends
and now you can just look on your phone
and feel like you know a content creator
or feel like you you FaceTime someone
and you you kind of lose the
family friends and close fam and the
family friends have a vested interest
well sort of I mean family friends can
fall out but if my mom's friends with
your mom and my dad's friends with your
dad then we have a vested interest in
keeping things cool because if I fall
out with you then it's gonna be a
problem with the parents it's going to
be a problem so and this also eliminates
sex
sexual assault right because
okay if you have a family you know I
don't want to say lemonades because a
lot of the molestation that stuff
happens inside families but it's often
because of negligent parents okay I'll
give you an example I'm I'm one of my
dad's 113 my mom's one of nine okay we
have a ton of family members so I'm not
trying to say this
to take a shot at anyone in my family
but okay that's a lot there's bound to
be a couple crazies I could tell you
what family members I personally would
want my children to stay away from
because you've known them your whole
life
and it's not to say like some kids are
crazy kids and they mellow out but you
have that sort of like accountability in
a way that like someone could have been
doing weird stuff till they're 20. you
meet them at 22. you have no vested
interest this is why also
and people would know each other's
families before getting married because
if I marry someone with no Mutual
connections or whatever families don't
know each other I mean
there can be a bunch of information up
to that point that you don't know or if
the families know each other
they've sort of grown up around each
other you know you've known them their
whole life you have so much more
information to choose from I'm not
saying
you can't do it on dating apps or on
Twitter any of that [__] I just found
out like Twitter's a dating app I just
saw tweet about look at I don't know now
but that's what I mean when I say like
we are Outsourcing
the family
and it's all because people choose to
not have a lot of kids and I was
thinking about this I'm like
we're so I was thinking maybe women are
naturally meant to have five kids
because a hundred years ago before the
food was all moved
before we all got fat before we were on
birth control all this stuff women had
five children so maybe that's like the
natural order of things and I was
thinking growing up
that was around the family size that I
really enjoyed
five kids because
once we got to six seven eight nine just
got chaotic
not to say you can't do that but like
five four five in the house at the same
time is good because you got siblings to
choose from if you don't like one you go
to another
um
people to do stuff with
yada yada
okay and okay also another thing
we're also Outsourcing the being the
number one influence on your kids
because we send them to school so before
now I don't know how prevalent
homeschooling was I should Google this
but
before the mother was the primary
influence on the kids now I'm not saying
we can go back to 100 years ago clearly
like I'm thinking of me personally
there are a lot of skills that you need
to have
to do homeschooling to do
like farm work you know and sorry we're
gonna go back to the food I'm so chaotic
I don't know back to the food
we Outsource Foods right so when you
Outsource the food they don't have a
vested interest in keeping your family
healthy so they're trying to make money
so they're going to make it taste the
best they're going to make it
the easiest to process like process all
that stuff where they don't have the
same vested interest but when
everything's in your family
it's true in a way what they say blood
is thicker than water because you all
have a vested interest in the outcome of
the family because you don't want a bat
if you don't want your name to be bad
around town you don't want to fall out
with family friends so you're forced to
keep relationships going longer where
nowadays it's like you're almost
Outsourcing community and Outsourcing
the family
I used to say I wanted two kids okay I
don't know I know all the comments are
gonna be like you gotta get moving okay
I'm doing my best all right I I don't
need to update you guys
and every part
of my life but please please don't worry
about that all right
that's the other thing y'all feel like
you need an explanation for everything
y'all think you gotta need to explain
give you every piece of information
about my dating look it I I don't need
to do that so
[Music]
sorry sorry I just I feel like the more
you tell people
the more about that area I just I've had
I've been in an experience where I had a
very public relationship and it was not
a good one I would not do that again so
anyways next next so okay back to this
we're Outsourcing be getting getting fit
right we Outsource that to a gym so
before we used to get fit by doing
housework with your family so then
you're getting closer you're cultivating
these relationships advice we used to go
to our grandparents our parents
if your grandpa's 90 years old you had
90 years of wisdom you don't think he
could teach you something even your
parents even if they're crackheads right
you don't think 60 years of just living
life
no advice and that's the thing people
will always say about me is like they
love hearing like I have a stream from
like seven months ago where my parents
came on and just the advice that they
would tell me growing up
it's invaluable
and so it's like you have these people
that have never heard basic advice it's
just basic like water is wet the sky is
blue and it's like these jet like I mean
Kevin Samuels had a stream on how to
shower and that's how far gone we are in
a society we have to YouTube things
because we've taken fathers out of the
home and we've also been Outsourcing the
fathers okay that's another one so
family advice we go to therapists
coaches teachers okay next we've
outsourced fatherhood
I'm writing this down because I may do a
full stream or something
we've outsourced fatherhood through
alimony
child support
alimony child support
um
government benefits
and honestly cushy jobs for women that
we don't really need like all those
women in Tech
all the women that just got fired in the
layoffs do you really think they were
worth if they were really worth that
much they would have survived the
recession
so
now we've we've officially so it started
with family like going to the gym
therapists okay and I'm sure you could
think of put other examples in the
comments now we have outsourced
fatherhood
okay where women are becoming the heads
of the household women
get get their kids 90 of the time and
we're told we don't need a man and
you're able they're able to get away
with this because they're they have
alimony child support government
benefits cushy jobs that we don't really
need in society but they have to fill
these quotas right
and I just found out the other day that
men because people are saying oh you can
sign off on your rights I just Googled
it yesterday apparently you can't even
do that like it's incredibly hard to
sign off imagine if men could just
easily sign away their rights of a kid
yeah oh so and abortion abortion that's
another way because before you would be
forced to start a family okay you got
pregnant Dad's getting a shotgun you are
marrying my daughter we are not doing
this we are not tarnishing the family
name and honestly my mom had to she's
from a small town there was two girls in
her graduating class that got pregnant
they're still with the guy today
they're still with the guy to this today
so and one of them actually ended up
like
she had a full career after the kids
were raised like she she became one of
those pilot like they direct the planes
or whatever I don't know
so not so
we now have outsourced fatherhood
and in the old days
there was really no reason to get
divorced like it was adultery addiction
I forgot like one other there's like one
other thing and I was thinking about
this what is the point of getting
married if you believe in divorce what
is the point because
you may as well just be in a
relationship if you believe that you can
get divorced for not being happy for
growing apart for all this [__] then why
even get married what is the point like
then you might as well just be in a
relationship
if you don't really believe in for
sickness and in health for richer for
poorer For Better or For Worse and
people used to they were so concerned
about keeping the family together that
they would separate even if they weren't
having sex they weren't together the
Public Image was separated they're not
divorced and
this is important because when you think
about it if Dad goes off and mom goes
off and they both get married to other
people
now what do Christmases look like like
my um my grandparents were um on one
side were separated when they died and
or when my grandpa dad my grandpas and
Grandma's still alive and it would have
looked like a completely different
Christmas if my grandpa ended up
remarrying and my grandma ended up
remarrying on separate sides
and it was weird they're separated but
they still did everything together so it
was kind of like they were together but
they weren't
but
now we've been told your happiness is
more important your
like there's no sense of Duty anymore
and
all the things that people used to do
together as a family have been
outsourced and I was thinking about
every summer going on vacation how all
the kids would complain about going on
vacation and I know you guys are
thinking brats okay but when your
parents make you hike 10 000 feet on
vacation you would understand why we
would complain it was like they're like
let's go to Colorado and Hike 10 000
feet
does that sound fun as a 15 year old
you're like yeah I want to miss summer
okay but when you think about it my
family said no no no no no no no no you
can either spend time with strangers or
spend time with family and when you
think about it
everything makes sense like your cousins
if everyone's having five kids in the
family
you all that's that's a million cousins
to choose from
and
again
Nick Fuentes he said this blood is
thicker than water and I'm like that is
so true because you have a vested
interest you don't want your family to
be known as crazy
if they're known as crazy around the
town that doesn't help you
and so we're Outsourcing all these
things
to strangers
family advice has gone to therapists
okay fatherhood has been replaced with
stepfathers child support alimony
government benefits so money that was
supposed to come from the dad is now
coming from the government so strangers
strangers sex ed is now being outsourced
to school so instead of talking to your
kids about sex that's now school's
talking about to your kid about sex
um getting in shape was supposed to be a
family activity housework farmwork
outsourced to strangers now I'm not
saying it's right or it's wrong I just
realized this pattern the other day
so let me know what you guys think in
the comments
um these are just random thoughts I have
sometimes
so I don't know like the video on your
way out also email list sign up in the
comments like the video on your way out
and I'll talk to you next time